.
AND LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS DO
REMAIN ABOUT FETTERMAN'S HEALTH.
>> FROM ERIE TO PITTSBURGH.
>> STEEL WORKERS.
>> PENNSYLVANIA'S DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE FOR SENATE, JOHN
FETTERMAN, BACK ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
MORE THAN THREE MONTHS AFTER
SUFFERING A STROKE.
>> IF I'M YOUR NEXT SENATOR TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., GUESS WHAT.
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE A
SENATOR THAT'S GOING TO BE
LIVING ACROSS THE STREET FROM
YOUR STEEL PLANT.
>> RALLYING MEMBERS OF THE
UNITED STEEL WORKERS TUESDAY,
FETTERMAN WAS ON MESSAGE BUT
OFTEN HALTING IN HIS SPEECH AND
OCCASIONALLY DROPPING WORDS.
>> BEING ANTI-UNION IS
ANTI-AMERICAN.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH DEMANDING FOR
AN EASY, SAFE KIND OF THEIR
INCOME, A PATH TO A SAFE PLACE
FOR THEM TO WIN.
EXCUSE ME, TO WORK.
>> FETTERMAN DECLINED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM CNN AND OTHER
REPORTERS AT THE EVENT.
A CAMPAIGN SPOKESPERSON TELLING
CNN FETTERMAN IS DOING REALLY
WELL, WALKING FIVE TO SIX MILES
A DAY, AND FOLLOWING DOCTOR'S
ORDERS.
THEY DIDN'T SAY WHEN THE PUBLIC
WOULD RECEIVE A STATUS UPDATE
FROM HIS PHYSICIAN ABOUT HIS
CONDITION.
INSTEAD, POINTING TO A JUNE
LETTER FROM HIS DOCTOR THAT SAID
FETTERMAN WOULD RETURN IN SIX
MONTHS FOR A CHECKUP, AND NOTING
A JULY INTERVIEW WITH THE
PITTSBURGH POST GAZETTE WHERE
THE 53-YEAR-OLD SAID HE HAD
NOTHING TO HIDE, WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING HE AT TIMES
STRUGGLING WITH HEARING, MAY
MISS A WORD OR SLUR TWO WORDS
TOGETHER.
>> IT'S ONE OF THE MOST COMMON
SYMPTOMS OF A STROKE.
THE SLURRED SPEECH DOESN'T
ALWAYS INDICATE A PROBLEM WITH
LANGUAGE PROCESSING.
SOMETIMES IT'S SIMPLY A PROBLEM
WITH PRONUNCIATION.
>> IN MAY, DOCTORS ATTACHED A
PACEMAKER WITH A DEFIBRILLATOR
TO HIS HEART TO TREAT HEART
DISEASE THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE HEART TO PUMP BLOOD
THROUGH THE BODY.
IN THE SAME INTERVIEW, FETTERMAN
SAID HE'S WORKING WITH A SPEECH
THERAPIST.
FETTERMAN'S HEALTH HAS EMERGED
AS A LINE OF ATTACK FROM HIS
RIVAL, CELEBRITY DR. MEHMET OZ.
ON DEFENSE RECENTLY OVER AN
APRIL VIDEO ABOUT CRUDITES AIMED
AT HIGHLIGHTING GROCERY STORE
PRICES, OZ'S CAMPAIGN RELEASING
A STATEMENT TUESDAY THAT SAID,
IF JOHN FETTERMAN HAD EVER EATEN
A VEGETABLE IN HIS LIFE, MAYBE
HE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD A MAJOR
STROKE.
FETTERMAN RESPONDING, I KNOW
POLITICS CAN BE NASTY, BUT EVEN
THEN, I COULD NEVER IMAGINE
RIDICULING SOMEONE FOR THEIR
HEALTH CHALLENGES.
FETTERMAN'S SUPPORTERS AT THAT
UNION RALLY DOWNPLAYING CONCERNS
OVER HIS HEALTH.
>> I THINK THAT HE'S BACK FAIRLY
QUICK FROM IT.
>> I THINK IF IT WAS A BIGGER
ISSUE THAN WHAT IT IS, HE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE MORE OPEN ABOUT
IT.
>> A KEY QUESTION NOW IS WHEN
WILL WE SEE THESE TWO CANDIDATES
DEBATE?
OZ HAS MADE THIS A CENTRAL
FOCUS.
FETTERMAN'S CAMPAIGN TELLING ME
FETTERMAN IS UP FOR DEBATING OZ,
BUT HAS NOT YET COMMITTED TO A
DATE.
JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, EVEN McKINNON IN
PITTSBURGH.
THANKS.
>> LET'S DISCUSS, CHARLIE, LET
ME START WITH YOU, A FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FROM
PENNSYLVANIA.
I HAVE TO SAY, I AGREE WITH
FETTERMAN.
I CAN'T REMEMBER A POLITICIAN OR
A CAMPAIGN IN PENNSYLVANIA
MOCKING SOMEBODY'S HEALTH
CHALLENGES.
HE HAD A STROKE.
I MEAN, IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
TALK ABOUT.
IT'S CERTAINLY A VALID ISSUE FOR
ANY CANDIDATE, BUT TO MAKE FUN
OF IT LIKE THAT, IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE READING THE ROOM OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> YEAH, MY ADVICE TO DR. OZ IS
TO NOT TALK ABOUT VEGETABLES
ANYMORE.
NEVER UTTER THE WORD CRUDITES.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
WAS.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS CRUDITES,
BUT HE'S GOT TO STOP THAT.
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
ABOUT JOHN FETTERMAN'S HEALTH.
MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE HE'S
UNDERSTATED THE SEVERITY OF HIS
SITUATION.
THERE'S BEEN A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, AND BEING A U.S.
CONGRESSMAN OR SENATOR IS A VERY
PHYSICALLY DEMANDING JOB.
AND YOU KNOW, HE'S NOT AGREED TO
ANY DEBATES THAT I'M AWARE OF SO
FAR.
SO THERE'S LEGITIMATE CONCERN
ABOUT HIS HEALTH, BUT YOU
SHOULDN'T MOCK THE CONDITION OR
HOW HE GOT THERE.
>> KASIE, YOU WERE THERE, WE SAW
FETTERMAN'S LAST EVENT BEFORE HE
HAD THE STROKE, AND AGAIN, JUST
TO UNDERLINE THIS, NOBODY IS
MAKING FUN OF IT.
WE ALL HOPE HIM A COMPLETE AND
QUICK RECOVERY, ET CETERA.
BUT YOU WERE THERE, AND YOU SEE
A DIFFERENCE.
>> YEAH, I THINK THERE'S A VERY
DISTINCT DIFFERENCE.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE WHO PRIDED
HIMSELF ON THE WAY HE INTERACTED
WITH VOTERS.
HE WAS A VERY EASY
CONVERSATIONALIST SPEAKER, I DID
AN INTERVIEW WITH HIM, HE TALKED
TO OTHER REPORTERS THERE.
HE'S NOT DOING THAT ANYMORE ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
AS IS ALWAYS THE CASE WITH
CANDIDATES' HEALTH, THE QUESTION
IS ARE YOU CAPABLE OF SERVING
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE RUNNING TO
REPRESENT?
RIGHT?
THAT IS THE IMPORTANT QUESTION.
AND THAT IS WHY IT BECOMES A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION.
TO YOUR POINT, I HAVE NEVER
SEEN -- I MEAN, HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE WE ALL BEEN IN RECEIPT OF
NASTY OPPOSITION RESEARCH,
SUGGESTING SOMEONE IS TOO OLD OR
SENILE OR WHATEVER.
WHATEVER THE PROBLEM MAY OR MAY
NOT BE, I HAVE NEVER HEARD
PEOPLE DO IT OUT IN PUBLIC LIKE
THIS.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE --
>> IT WAS A WRITTEN STATEMENT,
TOO, WHICH MEANS THEY THOUGHT
ABOUT IT AND HAD IT APPROVED.
>> IT ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE A TRIP
WIRE FOR OZ.
AND REALLY, MAYBE IT'S MORE LIKE
A TRAP DOOR BECAUSE AS A DOCTOR,
KIND OF THE CONDESCENSION TOWARD
FETTERMAN THAT BASICALLY THE
FETTERMAN CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO
TAKE THAT AND TURN IT AROUND AND
SAY HE'S TALKING ABOUT YOU.
YOU WHO LIKE ME DIDN'T LISTEN TO
YOUR WIFE AND GO TO THE DOCTOR,
ARE BEING MOCKED BY DR. OZ.
THAT'S WHY THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A POSSIBILITY FOR OZ TO GO
THERE.
I'M SURPRISED THAT THEY DECIDED
TO GO THERE.
MAYBE IT'S A MARK OF A SENSE
THAT THEY NEED TO GET TOUGH ON
FETTERMAN BECAUSE FETTERMAN HAS
BEEN RELENTLESSLY GOING AFTER
OZ ON SOCIAL MEDIA, BUT IT MAY
BE IN A WAY THAT I THINK FOR THE
VOTERS, THE AVERAGE VOTER, IT
NOT GOING TO PLAY WELL.
>> I FEEL LIKE THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE TRYING TO ATTACK HIM OR GET
AT HIS HEALTH, BUT THEY DID IT
IN SUCH A BONE HEADED WAY THAT
IT REALLY BACKLASHED, AND
ESPECIALLY FOR DR. OZ, WHO IS
SOMEONE FOLKS HAVE MADE FUN OF
SOME OF THE KIND OF THINGS HE
USED TO PUSH ON HIS SHOW